Hey, I'm Issa Rae,
and I play Issa Dee.
I'm Kendrick Sampson,
and I play Nathan Campbell.
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Why does he deserve a shot?
Even though it wasn't
the easy way,
he still chose to come back
and do it the hard way.
Nathan has not used his words
properly once.
...so he's not trying to be
aggressive with it.
He was trying to make sure
that you knew that he was sorry.
And then, you know...
...whenever she would allow
him to do so.
-We don't have to say creep.
-You said creep back in.
No.
We don't have to say "creep."
But I meant like, you know,
gradually come back in.
Says everything I needed
to know.
It doesn't have to say--
Just steadily and gradually.
Lawrence was here before Nathan.
In the most recent iteration
of their relationship...
So, that feels like
a clean slate.
(LAUGHTER)
Nathan got a lot going on.
He's still coming into his own.
-He's still--
-But he's doing well.
He accepted responsibility,
and he's working on himself.
He's going to therapy.
He's got this new barbershop.
At this point, for season five,
who knows what's gonna happen?
Do you know?
(LAUGHTER)
-ISSA: Season five.
-KENDRICK: Season five!